representing the government this morning
kit multis is with us now it's always
great to see thanks for joining us on
the program this morning um
how is the queen's speech going to help
people who are struggling with the cost
of living minister
well you'll have to uh allow me to avoid
a reprimand by the speaker by not
um previewing what's going to be in the
humble address as they say um uh
prince charles obviously will be
delivering it later so we don't have
long to wait but we are very focused on
some of the themes that you've been
talking about this morning first of all
obviously growing the economy as the
prime minister said i think yesterday
while we are putting significant
government spending behind assisting
people through this really challenging
period of of
price inflation
we have to bear in mind that we can't
spend our way out of this problem we
have to grow the economy and so looking
toward growth will be key uh the second
theme i think you'll start to see is
about keeping our streets safe obviously
my primary job in life is to make sure
that you and everybody else in the
country can sleep safely at night and go
about their business uh in safety too uh
the third area we'll be looking at uh
funding the nhs uh covert backlogs
making sure that we can get ahead of
that
as well as
showing some of the benefits if you like
of of brexit um in the legislation
that's brought through it's worth just
saying that okay as far as the the cost
of living crisis is concerned it is
incredibly challenging for people out
there at the moment obviously
legislation takes some time
to put in place it has to go through
both houses can often be many months
sometimes over a year before it hits the
statute book but i do know that the
prime minister the chancellor are in
constant conversation about how we can
be agile and assisting people through
this challenging time
um does that mean that we're potentially
we're looking at an emergency budget
uh well i don't know you'd have to get
the chancellor on and talk to him about
about that but i think he said in the
media yesterday that he is constantly
reviewing what he can do to assist now
we're obviously in a time of very
volatile fuel prices they are moving
around a lot uh we need to see a little
more i think he said yesterday about
where that fuel price is going to go
before we design uh what may come
forward um but we're very focused on
trying to give people as much help as we
can as you know we put 22 billion pounds
now of overall assistance into helping
people uh whether it's through their
fuel bills or through the the community
hardship fund now expanded to a billion
pounds focused on on the very um
those who are suffering the most in this
uh awful uh crisis but at the same time
our key objective is to get as many
people as possible into work and having
a thriving growing economy that provides
the employment they need using universal
credit to stimulate and help them into
work we think is the best solution for
families across the country
doesn't sound as though you're ruling it
out
well we don't rule anything in or
anything out i'm afraid you're asking
questions about my pay grade k uh that's
well you're representing the government
this morning minister no no no i am but
as i say you have to get them on i do
know that they are looking very very
carefully almost every day at how people
are struggling with their
with their prices of food and fuel and
the choices that they're having to make
and i know that they're giving it
careful thought about what the next step
should be what are the predictions
what's your prediction for uh inflation
by the end of the year
well i i'm a government minister so i
can't make a personal prediction to you
but obviously we look uh right with
alarm at the predictions that the bank
of england have made uh just in the last
week or so of inflation peaking towards
the end of the the year and we'll have
to think carefully about what our
response to that might be obviously the
bank is taking the measures it needs to
do by raising interest rates to start to
restrict that money supply to kind of
dampen things down a little bit so that
inflation doesn't get out of control and
i sincerely hope that works
how concerned are we that inflation
might get out of control i heard i i
recognize the fact that you said alarms
and as part of your last answer
well obviously
any rise in inflation above what we've
been used to which is at or around the
two percent mark is is a cause for
concern the bank is indicating that will
peak and then fall away uh which we all
have to work towards that includes them
in monetary policy and the uh chancellor
and fiscal policy but look okay in
amongst the the inflationary problems
that we're experiencing at the moment do
we do have to focus on the fact that the
post-covert economy needs to grow
um and so stimulating capital to invest
in businesses
looking at how we can turn all those
brilliant ideas that come fizzing out of
the british people um on an almost daily
basis into businesses which could become
world-beating at the same time is making
sure that as many people as possible can
access high-wage high-skill jobs giving
them the tools they need through
training and skills which nadeem is
doing with great aplomb so that they can
access those jobs too that's about our
future economy and that's where we need
to go
um i note with interest a couple of
years ago we were just looking at that
and the office this morning about august
2020 the
prime minister said there will be no
border down the irish sea over my dead
body is what he said um that's exactly
what we've got isn't it so what's the
government going to do about it
so we're obviously in close discussion
with the eu about the operation of the
northern ireland protocol i think it's
worth remembering
um that as we reached uh the
late stage of 2019 the house of commons
had effectively pulled the rug from
under the prime minister by taking no
deal off the
table and that meant that we went into
the brexit deal if you like the the
arrangements to leave um in the hope
that everybody would be flexible um
around the northern ireland protocol
sadly we haven't seen that very
legalistic approach uh from the eu but i
know that the foreign secretary is in
constant conversation with the eu um and
their negotiator about how we can make
that protocol
work for the whole of of northern
ireland obviously there is great
distress on the union side i don't think
there's any party that went into the
recent elections not asking for change
in the operation of the protocol i think
that needs to be recognized by the eu
and hopefully we'll see some flexibility
in the months to come
and does flexibility also potentially
include scrapping it
well look i can't uh predict what's
going to happen again that's a matter
for the foreign secretary but obviously
article 16 that sits in the boat is
there for a reason um
but i know that what we
fervently want to do is to reinforce
the belfast agreement the good friday
agreement uh maintain the um
if you like the settlement in in ireland
as a whole um but make sure that people
in northern ireland feel that their
rights as part of the united kingdom are
being respected um and prioritized and i
know that the foreign secretary will be
looking at that very seriously over the
weeks to come yeah but the majority in
northern ireland voted for parties
supporting the northern ireland protocol
so it would be inappropriate
um to
scrap it wouldn't it
i don't think that's right kay i think
all parties who are standing in the
election uh wanted changes in the
operation of the protocol
um and obviously i think most votes went
uh to a variety of parties who supported
a unionist uh position so you know we
need to bear in mind that we've got twin
objectives really first of all
the northern ireland is part of the
united kingdom and that integrity of the
united kingdom has to be preserved but
we also want to honor our commitment to
the good friday agreement
we think we can do that with some
flexibility around the operation of the
protocol and i
i know that the foreign secretary will
be talking to the eu chief negotiator
intensively over the weeks to come
particularly as we try and get that
executive back up and running um to try
and achieve that
um is the prime minister going to be
directly involved in brokering um a deal
for the uh power sharing fixing the
power sharing in northern ireland
because it's a mess
uh well look in the past as you know
prime ministers have taken a a leading
role in in northern ireland negotiations
i would imagine he's done the same he
did uh as much if you remember in the
negotiations with the irish government
leading up to uh brexit so he he stays
very close to his north alliance
secretary and i know that they talk a
lot about the negotiations and if
required i'm sure he he will
is it going to need the prime minister
to get involved because it is as i said
a mess at the moment what is the time
frame for trying to fix it well we
obviously want to fix it as soon as
possible because it's clear that
business in northern ireland
particularly is is not uh doing well out
of the protocol um and that needs to
change and i know the foreign secretary
is as to say in intensive conversations
as is the northern ireland secretary and
the prime minister will be as involved
as he needs to be to try and deal with
any deadlock should it arise it's a very
delicate situation at the moment we
recognize that and it requires everybody
to get round the table and to be
flexible if you like in their approach
to make sure that we preserve that
settlement that agreed settlement
through the good friday agreement in
northern ireland um is that a direct
appeal to the dep
not necessarily no i'm just saying we're
i'm being realistic about the situation
in which we we find ourselves um
as i say we we want to engage with the
eu with the irish government with the
dup to make sure that we reach an
arrangement that is satisfactory to
everybody
okay let's talk about um beer with keir
should we uh we we heard uh from kier
stamina saying i believe in honor
integrity and the principle that those
who make the laws
should follow them
um that's a direct dig at the prime
minister isn't it
possibly i don't know you'd have to ask
him look i i'm staying out of this one
as policing minister it would be
inappropriate for me and unwise to
comment on a situation where there's an
ongoing
police investigation um i haven't in in
other situations that have been similar
and i certainly won't uh in this i've
never been i have to say particularly
sensorious about other mp's conduct uh
how he conducts himself as a matter for
for his darling
if he's fine should he resign
again you'd have to ask him uh um
that's down to him he set his own
parameters for operation uh in the past
as i say i've never been sensorious
about the way other mps conduct
themselves try not to give advice to
other people uh other elected
politicians other than to say it's
unwise for anybody to comment on an
ongoing police investigation he says
he's going to go he says if he's fined
he will have to go he feels that that
would be the appropriate thing to do as
a result however you know you can dodge
it if you like but the prime minister
will also have to go if the leader of
the opposition resigns for the same
thing
well i'm not sure that's the case okay
but you're trying to draw me into
something that i really don't want to be
drawn and you have to recognize that as
policing minister i really should not
comment on a situation where there's an
ongoing police investigation we need to
leave the police space and time to do
their job with their usual commitment
and exactitudes and i'm sure in this
situation they will do as they have in
others well given that you're policing
minister how much pressure do you think
uh durham police are on denial
well you know durham police will operate
professionally uh to the high standards
that we expect of them uh irrespective
of what their
external goings-on are around this case
was as i say we need to leave them the
space and time to do that job i'm sure
they will and they'll reach their
conclusion in in due course um i did
okay if you wanted to cover some of the
public order stuff that we've got out
today okay i'm happy to talk about what
i'd like to talk about if that's okay
minister oh
thank you as far as durham police are
concerned
if
we do find that there they there's a
case to answer against kiyostama without
question they are going to have to find
themselves in something of a pickle
unless they again look at dominic
cummings and what happened in april of
2020 aren't they as policing minister
well kate as policing minister i need to
be very careful uh that i'm not
seen to be influencing who the police do
and don't uh pursue
um that is not my job my job is to set
the priorities nationally for the police
and that includes looking at murder
serious violence rape and sexual assault
neighborhood crime like burglary robbery
car crime which are happily down quite
significantly now um and so i i very
much i do the what i certainly don't do
the how and i would not dare to step
across the line and talk about specific
individuals no but would it not be
reasonable to assume that if there were
if there was um a high profile case that
was being looked at where someone was
found guilty of breaking the law of the
land and there was a similar breaking of
the law of the land potentially then you
would expect our police service that uh
you um our minister for at the moment to
look into at least consider that
because i say i i'm not okay you're
going to trying to draw me into making a
comment on ongoing investigations or
prospective investigations i really
don't want to i know it'll be reasonable
to expect that minister well i i really
i know twitter is going to go mad that
i'm avoiding the question but i really
do have to respect
uh the operational independence of the
police and allow them space and time to
do their job as they see fit that is
what we vest in them that is what we
trust them to do i trust them to do
things professionally every single day
and i really don't want to get into
into that debate if you don't mind i i
understand it's a public interest but
particularly in my position as policing
minister it just wouldn't be proper i'm
afraid but you do acknowledge it is of
public interest
well obviously the whole situation is of
public interest it's certainly of
interest to
the news media but as i say i i really
can't comment
okay good to talk to you thanks for
taking the time to join us on the
program this morning thank you